in the last couple of years I have
produced what I call the dead mall
series 32 short films and Counting about
dead malls now for those of you who are
not familiar with what a dead mall is
it's basically a shopping mall that has
fallen into hard times so it's either
has few shops and fewer shoppers or it's
abandoned and crumbling into ruin
no sale at Penney's I started producing
this series in early 2015
after going through kind of a dark
period in my life where I just didn't
want to create films anymore
I put my camera away and I just stopped
so in in in 2015 I decided to make a
short film about the owings mills mall
Owens Mills Mall opened in 1986 I should
know because I was there on opening day
I was there with my family along with
every other family in Baltimore and you
had to drive around for 45 minutes just
to find a parking spot so if you can
imagine that's not happen to get the
malls today my first mall job that I had
as a teenager was at a sporting goods
store called Herman's world of sports
maybe you remember Herman's
world of sports you guys remember that
yeah so I worked in a ladies shoe store
I worked in a leather goods store and I
also worked in a video store and not
being one who was very fond of the
retail arts
I got fired from every single job in
between these low-paying retail jobs I
did what any normal teenager did in the
1990s I shop lifted I'm just kidding I
hung out with my friends at the mall
everyone's like oh my god what kind of
talk is this hanging out at the mall
could be fun but it could be really lame
too like sharing a cigarette with a 40
year old unemployed mall rat who's put
on red or black lipstick for the night
while you're on your break from your
crappy minimum-wage job as I stand here
today
Owings Mills has been gutted and it's
ready for the wrecking ball the last
time I was there I was it was in the
evening and there's about three days
before they closed them all for good and
you kind of felt they never announced
them always closing but you had this
sort of feeling this ominous feeling
that something was big was going to
happen like it was the end of the road
it was a very creepy walk through the
mall let me show you
[Applause]
[Music]
so when I started producing the demo
series I put the videos up on to YouTube
and while I thought they were
interesting
I didn't think others which frankly I
didn't think others would share the
enthusiasm for such a drab and
depressing topic but apparently I was
wrong because a lot of people started to
comment and at first the comments were
like basically like oh my god that's
them all from my childhood what happened
and then I would get comments when
people who are like there's a dead mall
in my town you should come and film it
so I started to travel around the
mid-atlantic region filming these dead
malls some were open some were abandoned
it was kind of always hard to get into
the ones that were abandoned but I
somehow always found a way in the malls
did are still open they always did this
weird thing like the dead malls you know
they'll have three stores left but they
try to spruce it up to make it appear
like things are on the up-and-up for
example you'll have an empty store and
they bring the gate down
so at Owings Mills for example they put
this tarp over the gate right and it's
got it's got a stock photo of a woman
who's so happy and she's holding a
blouse and she's like
[Laughter]
and then there's a guy standing next
door with like an espresso cup and he's
like and and it says what brings you
today I wanted to be scared and
depressed thank you
so the comments just started kept
pouring in on the videos and from all
over the country and then all over the
world and I started to think this could
really be something but I had to get
creative because I'm like how long are
people gonna sit and watch me waddling
through an empty mall so I started you
know the original episodes I film with
an iPhone so I'd walk through them all
than iPhone and you know like that and
security cuz malls they don't they don't
like photography so that security will
come up and be like put that away and
I'm like okay so I had to get creative
and sneaky so I started using a hidden
camera and different techniques to get
the footage that I needed and basically
what I wanted to do was make the video
like it was a first-person experience so
like you are sitting put your headphones
on watching the screen it's like you're
there in the video like a video game
basically I also started to use music
collaborating with artists who create
music called vapor wave and vapor wave
is a music genre that emerged in the
early 2010's among internet communities
here's an example
[Music]
that's by an artist named dis conscious
and from an album he did call it
hologram Plaza so if you look that up
you can hear more of those tunes they
believe is more than an art form it's
like a movement it's nihilistic it's
angsty but it's somehow comforting the
whole aesthetic is a way of dealing with
things you can't do anything about like
no jobs or sitting in your parents
basement eating ramen noodles weber wave
came out of this generations desire to
express their hopelessness the same way
that the pre-internet generation did
sitting around in the food courts one of
my favorite malts i've been to is in
Corpus Christi and it's called the
sunrise small when I was a kid my
favorite thing to do was watch movies
and I used to watch movies over and over
and over again and one of my favorite
films was the legend of Billy gene now
for those of you who've seen the legend
Billy gene you'll know that it's a great
film I love it and it's Helen Slater and
Christian Slater if you didn't know they
are not related many people thought that
they were brother and sister they're not
but anyway son rides mall was used in
the film as it uses a filming location
the mall is exactly the same as it was
in 1984 we're talking 32 years later let
me show you and here's Billie Jean
running across the fountain being chased
by Hubie Pyatt friends and she jumps
over here and you can see this shot
right here is what it looks like today
[Music]
it's pretty incredible I mean honestly
it's exactly the same and there they are
falling in the fountain and she runs up
the stairs there's a nice shot of the
whole thing here I love that so much
I just think I always think in my head
I'm like if I owned a mall like a dead
mall like why don't they embrace their
vintage look like put in a bar like put
vegan food in the in the in the food
court and invite like Millennials and
hipsters to come and drink and eat and I
guarantee within like three weeks H&M
and Levi's will be banging on the door
trying to get space I don't know why
they didn't do this but apparently it's
only in my the mind it goes all day
anyway in closing when they first asked
me to do this talk I said do you have
the right person these talks were
supposed to be kind of like inspiring
and I I remembered something though I
said you know I I put my camera down
three or four years ago and it took
going to these malls for me to be
inspired again and to see my audience
and people from all over the world
writing me and saying god I love your
videos is incredible I don't know how to
even explain it as an artist how
fulfilling that is if you would have
told me a year ago that I would be
standing on this stage talking to all of
you wonderful people I would have never
believed it I am humbled and so
appreciative thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]